foreign
Pride discover the horrible truth about
their father
and dream of Vengeance
Neo confronts his own violent bloodline
and a terrible choice
the second Karma fears his own son's
Rebellion
of every Clan Has Its King how they
ruled will decide if you live suffer
or die
in The Savage King
SATA banished Queen of the North and her
two sisters
raise eight Cubs in Exile
Revenge boils in their blood
but survival comes first
[Music]
this Wasteland is no Eden
targets are few and far between
[Music]
thank you
strike while you can
spread out
seek weakness
here the meek don't inherit a thing
[Music]
thank you
here the meek will be eaten alive
[Music]
but this is just a snack
four ravenous daughters
and four insatiable Sons
demand much more
[Music]
survival is key to taking back the great
Marsh
[Music]
[Applause]
so Tau has set the table for a violent
Revenge
[Music]
thank you
only she can lead the northern Pride to
Victory
winter is coming
[Music]
the herds are on the moon
satire will follow
leading her family towards the great
Marsh
into the jaws of death for Glory
this is the backyard of their enemy
unlike the exiled Cubs in the north
sakacama's heirs are born into luxury
his youngest are his future
precious Secret
he kept hidden
foreign
here he can be a devoted father
a gentle protector
a trusted Guardian
[Music]
while his Queens are at work
dinner
[Music]
everything seems perfect
but the time has come for sakakama to
present his newest Cubs to the rest of
the family
all right
[Music]
not everyone will be pleased to see them
their free power-hungry half brothers
would kill them in a heartbeat
[Music]
[Applause]
their mother will let no harm come to
them
leave them alone
under secret Karma's rule these Cubs are
untouchable
the princes are jealous
they were once his favorites
show your loyalty
bide your time
second Karma may be old
but there is no one stronger
to lesser Mortals his Marsh pride means
only death
or leftovers
foreign
[Music]
Neo doesn't know how lucky he is
as keeper of leopard Rock
his mother gets first pick of the Marsh
pride scraps
[Music]
Neo is desperate to eat
but knows not to test Saba
thank you
[Music]
patience is a virtue he's slowly
learning
[Music]
never take leftovers for granted
Neo is a guest on his father's land
now dark eyes wants this meal
[Music]
and he takes what he wants
Saba knows he's dangerous
[Music]
Neo it's time to go
dark eyes tolerated you once
now your father will not stand for any
competition
all right
get out
[Music]
and stay on
Neil must find his own way
foreign
[Music]
how hard could it be
too many
[Music]
thank you
too fast
[Music]
perfect
foreign
[Music]
ah
harder than it looks
shells don't stop the voracious eight
they are hardened little killers
[Music]
they're growing strong
and ruthless
hunger makes them both
set our sense is a promising future
ahead for her Cubs
but they are hunting in a dangerous
neighborhood
[Music]
a mysterious Drifter has caught their
scent
[Applause]
thank you
lone males are never to be trusted
but he is the Cub's father
they've never met him before
they are in awe
unaware that he's a ticking bomb
the northern Queens do know he's the
trouble unpredictable
oh
quickly
get your precious Cubs out of his way
[Music]
distract him
appease him
do whatever it takes
[Music]
but sataw and her sisters bore him
his dark appetite
is for the little ones
fresh meat
the innocent Cubs want nothing more than
to play with their Newfound father
but he could kill every single one of
them
thank you
there is nothing you can do now SATA
[Music]
the violent Drifter moves along as
quickly as he arrived
Sato and her sisters assessed the damage
[Music]
everyone is still alive
but a bad father always leaves his mark
[Music]
foreign
fighter
but his future has been erased by his
own father
a good role model makes all the
difference
secacama is a leader
his pride will kill for him
um
his Queens do the Dirty Work
[Music]
foreign
by the throat and life drains quickly
sakakama rules with an iron claw
he demands discipline
order
obedience
[Music]
his youngest will eat first
under the hand of the king
the rest will wait
until he says so
[Music]
now you may eat
but
not you
the oldest Prince gets nothing
will respect the king's will
three
adding insult to hunger
if you don't like it
you can leave
[Music]
but psychetti has other ideas
and his resentment is growing
on Leopard Rock
Neil takes a small victory
not bad
but you cannot live off the men alone
Saba needs to find more
her home is Rich with prey
but nervous spies interrupt her hump
foreign
[Applause]
is trespassing on her land
a Wandering Huntress
with a son of her own
[Music]
the Intruder can recognize Prime real
estate
like Saba she also wants the best for
her son
[Music]
she leaves her boy to explore the
property
thank you
no one wants her here
but she's making herself at home
and shows every intention of staying
Saba cannot let her get comfortable
This Is My Land
[Music]
Saba will do anything to keep her hold
on Leopard Rock
thank you
take the fight to your enemy
make her leave
or risk losing everything
Saba is Victorious
but at what cost
[Music]
leopard rock is still hers
but a broken bone could be a death
sentence
for her and her son
[Music]
she's miles from home
Theo is all alone in a cruel world
[Music]
thank you
exposed and exhausted
Saba can go no further
[Music]
sat out on the Northern Pride have no
choice but to keep moving south
follow the food
but the injured Cub slows them down
[Music]
foreign
victims are getting harder to come by
[Music]
with only small kills
there's not enough to go round
it's everyone for themselves
hunger trumps compassion
yeah
those that can't keep up
will get nothing
the murderer's father tracks them down
he demands his pound of Flesh
he doesn't care where it comes from
his unspeakable Act
[Music]
foreign
the northern Queens must get away from
their Cannibal King
away from this place
all right
they still have seven lives to keep
[Music]
dreams of the marsh will have to wait
Neo's mother has been gone too long
is hungry
and tired of waiting
[Music]
foreign
and killers are on the prowl
run on high
leopard Rock will keep you safe
sir Kelly and his brothers are bullies
how to prove themselves
[Music]
they do not take prisoners
danger is closing in
[Music]
hold your breath now
don't make a sound
[Music]
the Marsh pride claims a young life
cut down by the murderous Trio
this is not about food
this is power
[Music]
control over all rivals
even sakakama seems proud of his sons
[Music]
power is intoxicating
thank you Saba is desperate to get home
to find her son
[Music]
but is she too late
where are you Neil
[Music]
foreign
trained him well
the victim was the trespassers less
cautious son
now they're both gone
[Music]
Saba's Fortress is intact
yeah
she can heal
[Music]
ing her son is safe
how many lives do you have left Neo
[Music]
all life is now on the marsh
life in Exile in the Badlands is
desperate
[Music]
subtle's quest for vengeance is now
just a fight to survive
[Music]
their murderer's father keeps them on
the Run
[Music]
no water
no food
scenario
[Music]
only Giants are left
thank you
so Town knows they stand no chance
against opponents this size
[Music]
the sisters cannot afford to lose
another cub
and starvation is never far away
[Music]
they need a miracle
foreign
[Music]
but the dry season's cruelty can also
deliver salvation
the Fallen victim might just get them
through
[Music]
not like this the marsh could still one
day be theirs
[Music]
patience will make the Vengeance even
sweeter
[Music]
Saba's lake is healing
she's still weak
but they must eat
[Music]
this time
she needs Neo's hope
[Music]
time to kill something big
Seize the Day new
[Music]
this is your moment
[Applause]
there is a hunter in you after all
thank you
the success marks his coming of aid
[Music]
but the change in Neo does not go
unnoticed
[Music]
dark eyes wants him out
are you not listening Leo
[Music]
is your father's fine
run away now
[Music]
and live to fight another day
Saba knows next time There Will Be Blood
[Music]
ready or not
you're on your own
[Music]
Neil will sharpen his wit and his
weapons
ready to claim his rightful Kingdom
[Music]
I will be back
not as your son
but as your nemesis
thank you
[Music]